[Musique]
chevalier jant dame et dame oiseaux
chevaliers et écuyers bienvenu au
médiéval de nafle le château ce weekend
le village a retrouvé ses origines
médiévales de jours de festivité
organisé par le Lyon club de nafle ont
transporté petits et grands à travers
les portes de
l'histoire le but final de l'opération
en dehors du plaisir de recevoir les
gens et de leur faire profiter d'une
belle fête c'est aussi de d'alimenter
les caisses œuvres sociales du liance
club de nfle Château ce qui nous
permettra dans les mois et les années
qui viennent bien sûr d'aider ceux qui
ont tendance à rester un peu sur le bord
de la route d'aider ceux qui essayent de
faire du bien à gauche et à droite
animation pédagogique spectacle marché
médiéval et location de costume ont
ainsi redonner vie au Moyen-Âge offrant
au visiteurs une immersion totale nous
voulait voir effectivement c'était le le
tournoi là des chevaliers puis après on
a essayé le tir à l'arc sur le sanglier
les différentes armes que nous présente
le camping
d'écossa après avoir découvert le camp
viking et admiré le dracard de Ron le
spectateur non initié ferru de
reconstitution historique a également pu
assister au tournoi international de jou
tquestre une véritable compétition entre
chevalier s'affrontant pour le titre de
la lance d'argent le style français
c'est on est souvent bon cavalier enfin
je dirais qu'en général on a un bon
niveau équestre
et on a la réputation d'être assez dur
en lance quoi no lances sont assez
puissantes voilà on doit avoir confiance
en l'adversaire qui vient en face de
nous on peut se faire extrêmement mal on
charge avec une lance donc il faut pas
qu'il y ait d'animosité il faut pas faut
vraiment que on reste dans le fairplay
donc ça veut dire qu'il y a le respecton
adversaire donc le respect des autres et
le fair playay c'est des grandes
qualités qui font partie bah qui qui
faisait partie du moyen-âge et euh de ce
que tu fait être un chevalier hein forte
admiration pour les valeurs chrétiennes
du Moyen-Âge pour un respect de Dieu de
la Parole du Seigneur
euh et d'un certain mode de vie qui en
découlait violent Bok B le juge
maintenant depuis notre siècle c'est
facile les mentalité a été adaptée à une
époque violente et je pense que quand
même le le respect de ces valeurs proche
du Seigneur faisait que le monde
fonctionnait correctement l'intégralité
des bénéfices de cet événement servira à
financer les œuvres sociales soutenues
par le lon club de noffle
[Musique]
lechâon